abone ol
bu evimiz yanıyor
ya ben bugün size futbolcu olacakken
nasıl ihtimal Twist olduğumu hikayesini
anlatacağım Benim büyük amcam vedam
zamanında Galatasaray'da ve Türkiye
milli takımında futbol oynamış kişiler
aynı zamanda teknik direktörlük de
yapmışlar
Dolayısıyla bizim mahallede bir futbol
kanı var
o bende 11 yaşına kadar futbol oynamayı
çok severdim Sol Ayağım çok kuvvetliydi
ama 11 yaşındaki radyo dinleme Tutkun
benim hayatım gidişatını tamamen
değiştirdi Bir Gün Okula Giderken açık
Radyo'da açık hasta programı dinliyordum
ve Gri tutun belgesindeki 15 yaşındaki
İsveçli bir kızın parlamentonun önünde
iklim için okul görevi yaptığını duydum
ya bu kadar Genç Bir Kızın geleceğinden
bu kadar haberdar olması ve haklarını bu
kadar savunuyor olması bana çok
etkileyici gelmişti Çünkü o zamanlar tam
kafamı da yapmamıştı okulu asıp daha
önemli bir konuya dikkat çekmeye çalışma
E tabi o zamanlar iklim krizi benim için
iklim değişikliği dedi yani O zaman
şöyle düşünüyorum belki biraz ekonomiye
zarar verir işte aynı şekilde tarıma
biraz zarar verir ama ben yaşarım
giderim zannediyordum
bu Kredi takip etmeye başlar
ve bu tatilin sırasında araştırma
yapmaya başladım ve Aslında pek öyle
düşündüm gibi olmadığını fark ettim
bir detay gibi dünyanın dört yanından
iklim adresleri çıkmaya başladılar kendi
ilçelerindeki illerindeki ülkelerindeki
parklarda parlamentolarda belediye
binaları önlerinde iklim için okul
görevleri yapmaya başladılar ben de bir
şeyler yapmak istedim ve tam o sırada
gratin work bu onbeş Martta
2019'a Bir küresel iklim grevi çağrısı
yaptı
bu sonra STK Lara sormaya başladın
internette araştırdım sosyal medyada
Baktım ama Türkiye'de henüz ne bir çağrı
ne de bir grev hazırlanıyordu ne de bir
duygu ne de bir şey duyurulmuştu
ve sonrasında yaklaşık üç hafta kalan
aileme dedim ki bu çağrıyı ben yapmak
istiyor
ve sonrasında bir pankart hazırladım
küçük bir çağrı metni ile birlikte
sosyal medyada Çağrı videomu çıktım açık
gaste programında çağırıldım açık radyo
ile iletişime geçtikten sonra ve oraya
gidip dedim ki
Ya ben Atlas taraf oğlum 11 yaşındayım
hepinizi onbeş Martta bebek Parkı'na
bekliyorum aynı zamanda Bugün de deneme
ve tanışma amacıyla bebek Parkı'nda
olacağım yine hepinizi bekliyorum dedim
açık radyo programının çok başarılıydı
Bana kalırsa sonrasında bebek Parkı'na
gittim
iyi bilen bekliyordum tanışma dediğim
gibi deneme amacıyla küçük bir görev
yapacaktık
var ama kimse gelmedi
O bir hafta kaldı ve o bir haftada
geçtikten sonra pilav yeni geldi çattı
bebek Parkı'na gittim ve Kafamda şöyle
bir düşünce vardı En azından bir 50-60
kişi gelsem kalabalık oluruz 2/3 basın
gelsem belki sesimizi duyurabiliriz
demiştim
ve o gün oraya 700 kişi geldi
ve yerel uluslararası basın hepsi
oradaydı
O zaman neden de oradaydı Dedem 90
yaşında kendisinin bunu anlıyor olması
bana bu davamda bu konuda destek veriyor
olması benim için çok önemli
Ben de demin pankartında yazılı olan
kelimeler cümle şuydu
Sizden özür dileriz gençler
E tabii bir grev yapıp Bırakmayacaktın
Çünkü bir görev yaptıktan sonra ipimizi
durmuyor Dolayısıyla ben de duramazdım
devam etmem gerekiyordu
sonrasındaki ileri gezmeye başladım
şehirlerde Ayvalık Datça Ankara İzmir
Edirne ve daha birçok yere gidip orada
tiyatrolarda STK ların hazırladığı
panellerde karar vericilerle bekle
toplantılarda iklim turizmi tartıştım bu
okullarda sunumlar yaptım okullarda
sunumlar yapmanın benim için ayrı bir
yeri var çünkü şu andaki eğitim
sistemimizde iklim değişikliği
kitaplarda Bir sayfadan atılıp geçiliyor
ama insanın karşı karşıya olduğu en
büyük varoluşsal kriz Bence okul
kitaplarında bir sayfada anlatılıp
geçirmemeli İşte bu da benim aklıma çok
yatmıştı
Dolayısıyla sunumlar yaptı
ve sonrasında bu da yetmedi
bu
İsviçre'ye ve İspanya'ya gittim ilk önce
İsviçre Lozan da bir iklim Hatta iklim
aktivisti yaz kampına katıldım orada
yaklaşık 450 maddesi vardı ve orada bir
hatayla tanıştım Aslında ben yemek
alıyordum kahvaltı sırasında yaydım ve
bir anda gözlerimin önünde bileti gördüm
tabii inanamadım gözlerime Çünkü aslında
iklim konusunda ve iklim aktivisti olma
yönünde Beni ilk etkileyen kişi
gözlerimin önündeydi
daha sonra gittim Biraz konuştuk Sohbet
ettik haftanın geri kalanı birlikte
etkinliklere katıldık
ama bununla birlikte orada bir sürü
kişiyle daha tanıştım Nobel ödüllü bilim
insanları fizik profesörleri iklim
değişikliği profesörlerinden iklim
değişikliği öğrendim bilimsel tarafını
öğrendim yokuş isyanın kurucusu yine bir
iklim hareketi Rocher halımdan sivil
itaatsizlik öğrendim yani karar
vericilere politikacılara taleplerimizi
ve düşüncelerimizi nasıl doğru bir dilde
iletebiliriz öğrendim bu ve bir hafta
böyle güzel geçti gitti bu haftanın
sonunda bir tane büyük bir ev yaptık o
görevde lozan'ın bir Bulvarı'nda
yaklaşık 4000 5000 kişi bir yürüyüş gel
evindeydik sonrasında bir toplanma
noktasına geldi toplama noktasında bir
sahne kurulmuştu
ve o sahneye çıkıp insanlar
ülkelerindeki iklim problemlerinden
iklimle ilgili yaşanan sorunlardan
bahsediyorlardı en azından sözü yaymak
için İnsanları bilgilendirmek için
durumdan
bu sonra ben de çıktım ve Türkiye'deki
bir hikaye anlat
Bu bir One Karakeçili hikayesini
anlattım ben
11 Van 13 yaşında bir tarım işçisi Bir
Çocuk işçi bir portakal bahçesinde
çalıştırıyordu ve patronları o kadar
acımasızlığı ki gökten taş yağdı bile
Siz çalışmaya devam edeceksiniz diyordu
bu Berivan hayatında gördüğü ilk
fırtınada kafasına bir saç defa gelerek
yaşamını yitirdi beni nasıl korktuğum
şey bir Van'ın öldü yaş Benim şu anda
oldum yar
da aslında bunun gibi bir sürü daha
iklim adaletsizliği hikayesi olduğunu
bildiğim için
bunları da yaymaya ve anlamaya çalıştım
Bununla birlikte de insanlarla
röportajlar yaptım O Yaz kampında
tanıştığı insanlarla ve daha birçok
insanla birlikte röportajlar yaptım hala
devam ediyorum
İsviçre'den sonra
bu İspanya Madrid de gittim orada kopya
meşe katılın Birleşmiş Milletler iklim
izlemesini 25'ine yine Great oradaydı
iki matriste arkadaşlarım oradaydı bilim
insanları oradaydı var ama karar
vericiler de oradaydı bunun başka bir
önemi var çünkü iklim aktivistlerin
Aslında yönelmek istedikleri kişiler
yani mesajlarını iletmek istedikleri
kişiler politikacılar
bu Fakat kopun çok başarılı olduğunu
söyleyemeyeceğim Çünkü iklim
aktivistleri bir oturma eylemi yaparken
kokun içinde Kaptan atıldılar
bu ama maddede gittiğimizde çok başarılı
bir grev gerçekleştirdik
bu yaklaşık 500 bin kişi yarım milyon
insan bir yürüyüş bir ev yaptık
mi Evet oradaydı
ve görevden sonra anladım ki
Allah herkesin yapabileceği en az bir
şey var
Ya ben iklim aktivisti olmayı seçtim Siz
iki maddesi olmak zorunda değilsiniz Ama
hak savunuculuğu nun birçok yolu var
ama bence Siz de kendinize sormalısınız
Ben bu konuda ne yapabilir
Evet şimdi ben kendi yolumu üzerinden
Sizin nasıl iklim aktivisti
olabileceğinizi 4 adımda anlatacağım
bir adım Bir farkına var Yani aslında
buzulun görünmeyen kısmı görmeye
çalışacağız
var yani buzul eridikten sonra mozaik
kuyruklu farenin türünü denizlerin
seviyesini yükselterek yok ettiğini
bilmiyoruz bunları Bilmemiz gerekiyor ya
da plastiği o kadar fazla üretmiş iz ki
dünyanın en alçak noktası olan Mariana
Çukuru ve en yüksek noktası olan Everest
Dağı'na İnsanlardan önce Plastikler
ulaşmış
en korkunç
bu Bununla birlikte şu anda gördüğünüz
etkileri somut olarak tabii ki
görebiliyoruz Ama eğer böyle devam
edersek ileride daha kötü etkilerini
görebileceğiz yani bilimsel olarak Ama
bunlar 2030 yılında 200 milyon iklim
göçmenin beklenmesi olabilir birikimin
göçmeni diye yeni biterim çıktı çünkü
bunlar farklı bir farklı bir göç konusu
yani aşırı sıcak dalgaları Fırtınalar
Seller ve daha birçok şeyden dolayı
insanlar doğdukları büyüdükleri yerden
göç etmek zorunda kalıyorlar
o o
mi Evet farkına vardıktan sonra iklim
krizinin ne olduğunu anlayabiliyoruz ama
ayrıntılar etmemiz gerekiyor Yani
insanlar anlatabileceğimiz ayrıntıları
mız detayları mız bu konunun daha can
alıcı konularını öğrenmemiz gerekiyor
Dolayısıyla ikinci adımızda
bu bilimi Merkez al yani hep bilimi
gözümüzün önünde tutacağız bilime ara bu
konuda araştırmalar yapacağız yani son
10 yılda 10 milyon futbol sahası
büyüklüğünde yerin yok edilmesi gibi
Amazon yağmur ormanlarında Evet ağaçları
yıllardır kat ediyoruz ormansızlaştırma
yapılmış yapılıyor Peki ağaç kesmek
neden kötü bir şey Neden hala devam
ediyoruz yani o acı kestiğiniz zaman
size oksijen yani yaşam sağlayan bir
forma bir canlıyı kat ediyoruz Evet bunu
yıllardır yapıyoruz
var ama ağacın içindeki karbondioksit de
havaya sağlıyoruz ve Bilin bakalım bu ne
sebep oluyor küresel ısıtma Evet
mi Evet oraya getirilen yeni yapılar
Tabii ki yine hayvancılık tarım sanayi
üretim tüketimi katkıda bulunduğu hizmet
ettiği için yine kötü
mi Evet dünyada 2 milyar insanın Dünyası
raporuna göre p temiz suya düzenli
erişimi yok
aslında bilime anlamaya bilime inanmaya
başladığımız zaman fosil yakıtlar
bırakmanın bir çözüm olduğunu
anlayacaksınız ha bu size çok gerçekçi
görünüyor olabilir ama bana da bir
geleceğimiz olmayacağı çok gerçekçi
görünmüyor açıkçası
13. adımız
bu çevremizi anlatacağız ve her iklim
adresini yapacağı gibi sözü yayacağız
Biz Yani ben ilk iklim sunumu 1 ve 2
sınıflara atmıştım onlara bahsettiğim
konu Prens evrelerinin rekor yaptığı
parlamentodan artık iklim anlaşmalarını
geçirmemiz gerektiği di veya Great aydı
ama onlar tabi 1 ve 2 sınıf oldukları
için beni anlattığım matematiksel
sayısal veda komple Konuları çok iyi
anlayamadılar Hani sunumun sonunda ki
bana bakışlarından anlayabiliyordum onu
sonra onları etkilenmem gerektiğini ve
son bir cümlem olduğunu hatırladı
de dedim ki şu anda iklim krizinin
etkilerini görüyoruz ama ileride daha
somut etkileri görebileceğiz mesela
dünyada su bulamayacağız bal
bulamayacağız çikolata bulamayacağız
dediğim anda sınıfta bir kıyamet koptu
Dolayısıyla herkese iklim krizine ve
farklı farklı yönlerden ve yollardan
anlatmam gerektiğini anladım Yani bir ne
iklim krizi veya önemli bir konuyu
anlatırken
bu gözümüzün önünde bulundurmamız
gereken konular var onları hangi konu
başlıkları etkiliyor onların yaşamını ya
da yaşları olabilir bu işleri olabilir
Ben ne yapıyorum çevrem anlatırken
Bu benim Birader programı var açık araca
da aynı zamanda aylık bir dergide köşe
yazarlığı yapıyorum ve röportajları
devam ediyorum hatta o röportajlardan üç
tanesini Şimdi size anlatmak istiyorum
Çünkü aslında üçüde benim arkadaşım ve
başlarına mutsuz edici haberler geldim
37 şeyler geldi şimdi onlardan bahsetmek
istiyorum size ilk arkadaşım şimdiden
bu iklim aktivisti olduğu için okulundan
atıldı ve ülkesinde eğitim göremiyor
yıkım abdestini bırakması gerekiyor ya
da başka bir ülkeye gitmesi gerekiyor
ama o iklim görevlerine devam ediyor
Rusya'daki arkadaşım Rusya hükümeti
toplu bir evleri yasakladığı için tek
başına görev yapıyordu ama polis
tarafından defalarca gözaltına gözaltına
alındı Ve 14 günlük bir hapis cezasına
çarptırıldı kendisi cree görevlerine
devam ediyor bu Hindistan'da ki
arkadaşım kendi daha dokuz yaşında ve
altı yaşındayken Hindistan'da ki çocuk
hareketini başlattı
Ben de geçenlerde parlamentonun önünde
bir basın açıklaması bir konuşma
yaparken gözaltına almak istedi daha
dokuz yaşında bu iklim görevlerine devam
ediyor
ve böylece hem son adımıza da geldik
bu harekete geç
Eğer birlik olacağız birleşeceğiz ve
organize olarak harekete geçeceğiz
yapmamız gereken şey bu
en uzun zamandır uyuduğunuz uykunuzdan
artık uyanmamız gerekiyor birlikte bir
şeyler yapmamız gerekiyor
çünkü bugün acil durum veya krize kriz
demezsek mi krizi çözemeyeceğiniz
bu Eğer Mesleğiniz bir öğretmen olmak da
bir öğretmensiniz çocuklarınıza iklimi
sahiplenme lerini söyleyebilir Bunu
öğretebilirsiniz onlara Eğer bir haberci
iseniz gazeteci iseniz iklim konusunda
haberler yapabilirsiniz Eğer bir
müzisyen ya da şarkıcı sanız Bununla
ilgili müzikler yazıp şarkılar
söyleyebilirsiniz
var ya da işyeri sahibi iseniz yeşil
politikaları işyerinize Entegre
edebilirsiniz
ve dayanışmanın gücü politikacılara Daha
doğrusu karar vericilere yeterli baskı
yapacaktır
bu çünkü Eğer evimiz yanıyormuş gibi
bağırsak sesimizi duyurabiliriz
bu çünkü evimiz gerçekten yani
bu Bizde ise kim şimdiyse ne zaman
Teşekkürler
[Alkış]
beraber ha